>> John: BLUES TAKEOVER AND
PRESSURE THEN THEY HAVE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF GAMES. IT UP THE,
KEPT IN BY MILLER.
PUMPS AT BELOW THE LINE. AND BAW
BETWEEN KYROU AND ROBERT THOMAS.
IT ALL STARTS HERE,DING TO
FORBES.
>> John: SO THE GOALACE-OFF BACK
HERE.
THE BLUES DO A GREAT
SAAD A TO THROW AROUND HIS BODY.
I REALLY LIKE WHAT I'M SAYING
OUT OF THE YOUNG KID SORK
DOWN THERE, COLTON PARAYKO DID A
GREAT JOB OF HOLDING THE LINE A.
NOW THE BACK AFTER MISSING THE
LAST 11 WITH A LOWER BODY ABLE S
ARE NEW YORK WENTWON 5 OF  SIX .
BRAYDEN SCHENNSECOND MARK.
NOW BORTUZZO TO CENTER.
BABA
THOMAS ON IT.
THEY'VE GOT TO BE EXHAUSTED,
CHASING THE THE BLUES WERE JUSTG
THE ENTIRE TIME.
JAKE WALMAN HERE GETS  IS WIPED.
THE VETERANS, SCHENN, O'REILLY,
PERRON
X5S, ALREADY FOR IMMEDIATE JUSTN
INCREDIBLE SAVE ON THAT LAST
ONE.
THE RANGERS I AM SURE PASS, PAN.
WIDE OPEN, HUNT, REBOUND, STROMR
THE RANGERS, THEY ARE PLAYING
WITH RECKLESS A OUT.
STEERED STICK BY GOAL.
BOTH NEW YORK NETTING.
>> Jamie: VILLE HUSSO, WE TALK
ABOUT HOW GREAT HE HAS MIDWAY PT
OF THE THIRD PERIOD.
BLUES GET IT OUT.
MacEACHERN, LITTL
FREE, AND ONTO THE NET, AND HE
CAN'T PULL THE TRIGGER.
O'REILLY GETS
AWAY.
TARASENKO TRYING TO TIP IT